English is spoken in so many countries
with so much diversity there's British
Australian kiwi American Canadian and
South African English ah Jesus you
forgot about Irish English you big egy
oh right people sometimes forget about
Ireland or they think it's part of
Britain but Ireland is not part of
Britain not even this part and the
varieties of English spoken in Ireland
known as Irish English or hiberno
English have their own unique features
that set them apart from the varieties
spoken in Britain and elsewhere in both
Ireland and Northern Ireland there are
two official languages English by far
the most widely spoken language and
Irish or gelic the original indigenous
language of the island it was largely
displaced by English during the time of
England's colonial rule and suppression
Ireland was first invaded by the
anglo-normans in the 12th century making
Norman French the language of the ruling
class while Irish was spoken by the
natives and English was spoken by Common
settlers who arrived from Great Britain
but most of these English-speaking
settlers were eventually assimilated
into the Irish culture and language and
the English crown lost control of most
areas outside of the pale which included
Dublin and surrounding areas the English
language took more of a foothold after
England reconquered Ireland in the 16th
century the English crown confiscated
Land from the Irish and populated it
with English-speaking settlers and the
Irish language and culture were heavily
suppressed until around the year 1800
the majority still spoke Irish but
English was the prestige language and
was necessary for social and economic
opportunities so it was becoming more
and more adopted by Irish speakers then
the Great Famine of the 1840s had a
disproportionate impact on the rural
poor leading to a steep population
decline particularly of Irish speakers
around a million people died and a
million more emigrated this was an
important factor in Ireland's shift from
Irish to English the vast majority of
the Irish population now speaks English
as a native language and not Irish but
Irish left its imprint on the Island's
varieties of English as Irish speakers
adopted The Prestige language English
the way they spoke it was influenced by
their original native language keep in
mind that most Irish people who learned
English were illiterate and had no
formal education in English and its
grammar so they naturally didn't follow
all of its rules it's also worth noting
that most of the British settlers spoke
dialectal forms of English and Scot
rather than Standard English so the
language the Irish were acquiring was
not the standard language to begin with
so some of the features of Irish English
originated in various dialects of Great
Britain especially the southwest and
Midlands region as well as Scots
dialects of Scotland of course with the
expansion of education and literacy
Standard English began to influence
Irish English more so Irish people
adopted dialectal English with influence
from Irish plus later influence from
Standard English and also some unique
development ments in Irish English today
there are several overarching dialects
or accents of Irish English including
the traditional dialect of the Dublin
area referred to as local Dublin the new
Dublin dialect which is more
International in nature and less
distinctly Irish the Western dialect the
southwestern dialect and the northern
dialects or oler dialects there's also a
variety of English spoken all over the
Republic of Ireland which is similar to
the new Dublin dialect in the sense that
it excludes many overtly Irish features
but in this video I want to focus on
overtly Irish features even if not
everyone uses them Irish English has
some distinctive features in terms of
accent vocabulary and grammar we'll talk
about those features in a minute but
first I'd like to tell you about an
online language school I recommend you
check out lingoda where you can learn
English business English Spanish French
or German online with native speaking
teachers you can book classes 24/7 which
can be scheduled for any time of the day
and right now with lingoda Lang language
Sprint challenge if you take 15 classes
in 30 days you'll get a 50% cash back or
15 lesson credits the equivalent of a
100% cash back that's what I would pick
or you can take the Super Sprint
challenge which is for 30 classes in 30
days I've taken French classes on
lingoda before when my speaking was
quite Rusty and I needed a refresher
lingoda offers structured lessons and
courses with fixed lesson themes and
downloadable study materials so you can
preview and review which gave me the
confidence to jump back into speaking it
was really exciting and motivating
whether you're like me and have some
previous knowledge of the language or
you're a beginner lingoda classes are a
great way to learn and imagine how much
you'll improve with the powerful
incentive of a 50% cash back pushing you
to study with a native speaking teacher
every day to join the language Sprint or
Super Sprint click the link in the video
description and use my discount code
Lang Focus to get $25 off and right now
during Black Friday month you'll get an
extra 30% discount you can become one of
the more than 177,000 students who've
won The Challenge on the lingoda website
you can also take part in a special
Black Friday raffle or Fortune Wheel for
the chance to win additional prizes you
can only sign up for the language Sprint
for a limited time so use my link in the
description to visit the lingoda website
now and now back to features of Irish
English accent there are many Irish
accents not just one but there are some
features that are present in most
accents let's take the name of the
country Ireland notice that you can hear
a clear R sound Irish dialects are rodic
meaning that all of the r sounds are
pronounced at least in most accents this
immediately distinguishes Irish English
from most varieties of British English
in which R is not pronounced after a
vowel unless it's followed by another
vowel they say it more like
Ireland some other features voiced the
is normally pronounced d and voiceless
th is normally pronounced th t thirsty
are you thirsty that there that thing
over
there the G of in often isn't pronounced
in other words in is pronounced in he's
fixing that old shed of ours this
happens in other varieties of English
too but it seems particularly common in
Irish English the diff thong in words
like mouth is pronounced e in Dublin M
hour flow out this differs depending on
region as a lot of vowel sounds do but
at least in Dublin this sound is the
norm the a vowel plus r sound in car is
more like r at least in the traditional
local Dublin Accent car Garden start
marble the diff thong in choice is more
like chice at least in some accents we
haven't got any chice in the M these are
some general features of pronunciation
but remember that there are various
accents
vocabulary while Irish English uses
mostly the same vocabulary as Standard
English it also has some of its own
distinctive vocabulary and expressions
here are some examples yoke Irish people
use the word yoke to refer to inanimate
objects in general especially when they
can't immediately recall the name of it
I'm looking for that Yoke the Yol I
bought yesterday where I'm from in
Canada we might say thingamajig or
thingy Another Irish word is crack which
means a good time or news or gossip
what's the crack horse this is like
asking what's up dude also notice that
the word horse can be used like dude or
bro in North American
English bold Irish people use the word
bold with the meaning of mischievous or
disobedient especially with regards to
Children the standard meaning of bold is
courageous or daring which in Irish
English extends into daring to break the
rules he was acting bold in school today
the use of bold with this meaning is an
archaism that has survived in Irish
English this is also the case for Grand
Irish people say Grand with the meaning
of fine good or great how are you I'm
Grand thanks also notice the abbreviated
way of asking how are you how are
you deadly Irish people say deadly to
say something's awesome or amazing that
was a deadly concert the words lethal
and class can be used in the same way
both as adjectives including in class
that concert was class that song is
lethal Irish people might use the word
Ry with the meaning of dangerous or
unwell this is a ropy area that Sushi
made me feel
ropy a word for house or home is Gaff we
have a nice Gaff on the
coast a slang expression for the
lavatory in Irish English is the jack
you should visit the Jacks before we
leave it's going to be a long drive if
someone's acting foolish or acting like
an idiot an Irish person might say there
acting the maggot this can be said in
either a serious or a playful way stop
acting the maggot you if someone's
annoying you you can refer to them as a
head wer head wrecker he's a head
wrecker he never answers when I call him
you could also say wreck the head as a
noun he's a wreck the head or you could
use a verb phrase he's wrecking my head
he was acting old in school today
wrecking the teacher's head Irish
English has plenty of idioms like this
here's another one up to 90 which means
very busy or overworked I've been up to
90 all week with my
exams there aren't too many lone words
from the Irish language in Irish English
though there is a handful one common one
is slanta this word means
cheers grammar there are also some
grammatical peculiarities of Irish
English some of which stem back to the
influence of of the Irish language and
some of which are remnants of early
stages of the English language these
features are not always used they're
used to varying degrees alongside their
Standard English equivalents here are
some examples there's a plural form of
you use I meet you outside the cinema I
heard you are planning a trip in Dublin
you might also hear a plural possessive
adjective yeser instead of your give me
is our plates so I can put them in the
dishwasher them them sometimes used as a
demonstrative adjective or demonstrative
pronoun instead of those them books on
the table is mine also note that
sometimes a plural subject takes a
singular verb conjugation in Irish
English books is rather than books are
stay away from damn kids down the street
you might hear the same feature in other
non-standard dialects of English which
likely came from the influence of Irish
English there's no plural ending for
nouns of time or measure 2 year 100 mile
I was working there two
year TI is a common contraction of it is
instead of its also TW for the past
tense it is raining outside it was a
good night to my ears this sounds quaint
and old-fashioned like something from a
traditional Christmas song or story like
TW the night before Christmas or t the
season to be jolly that's because this
type of contraction was common in
standard English in the past but I
survived mainly in Irish English the
definite article the is sometimes used
where we wouldn't use it in standard
English this is probably because of the
influence of the Irish definite article
which has a wider range of uses than the
English definite article Standard
English that is for example the most of
instead of most of and the both of
instead of both of I already ate the
most of me dinner let's invite the both
of them to the
party using the one with the meaning of
the same we ended up wearing the one
outfit to school
for some time Expressions I go to the
gym twice in the week and there are
numerous other cases when the appears
where it wouldn't in standard English in
Irish English reflexive pronouns can be
used on their own with no antecedent in
subject or object position or as object
of a preposition myself and Paul are
very happy to be here look at this photo
here's
myself another characteristic of Irish
English is its different ways of
expressing the perfect aspect though the
Standard English way is used as well
maybe the most noticeable is the after
perfect consisting of after plus ing or
a noun phrase I'm only after finishing
work meaning I've just finished work
we're after getting home from Cork
meaning we've gotten home from Cork this
is one feature of Irish English which I
really found confusing the first time I
heard it there's also the indefinite
anterior perfect like were you ever in
instead of have you ever been to were
you ever in France yeah treat times I
was in France you heard that story
before did you rather than Standard
English you've heard that story before
have
you there's also the extended now
perfect to express an action that began
in the past and is continuing now no I'm
not working here long rather than
Standard English no I haven't been
working here long the be perfect in this
form the auxiliary is to be rather than
to have all of them are left already the
people are going mad this type of
perfect can only be used with
intransitive verbs because otherwise
you'd have sentences that can be
confused with passive sentences like
this the tourists are all eaten
now Irish English also has some
interesting ways of expressing habitual
aspect in other words actions that you
do regularly one way is by using do plus
b they do always be losing their keys
another way is by using the S inflection
when it otherwise wouldn't be there it
goes every
Wednesday in Irish English embed Ed
questions can be asked without inversion
I wonder is it better to call or to send
a DM rather then I wonder if it's better
the lack of if in the sentence likely
reflects the fact that in the Irish
language there are no embedded questions
with if or
whether Irish English sometimes uses
resumptive pronouns in relative clauses
rather than explain what that means let
me just show you over there is a field
that we used to play in it this is the
show that I used to watch all the time
if you can't hear the word it in the
sentence that's because the speaker is
pronouncing the T as a glottal stop
between vowels which is common in North
Dublin Accents in standard English this
would be play in and watch without it
this most likely comes from the
influence of the Irish language which
has resumptive pronouns just like this
resumptive pronouns are becoming less
and less common in Irish English these
days but are sometimes still
used the word and can introduce a
subordinate clause instead of while the
phone rang and I was eating me dinner
rather than while I was eating my dinner
in Irish English the syntax of a
sentence sometimes changes to Mark the
focus or topic of a sentence one way is
through fronting the Rainbow Bar they
call it without fronting it would be
they call it the Rainbow Bar in this
case the name of the place is the focus
so it moves to the front of the sentence
drank all night we did without fronting
it would be we drank all night in this
case the verb phrase drank all night is
is fronted because the focus is on the
activity of drinking and because you
can't have the subject sitting all by
itself with no verb the meaningless do
is inserted as did another way of
showing focus is with clefting using it
to turn a single clause sentence into a
two clause sentence this is done in a
certain way in standard English it's an
apple that she's eating without clefting
this would be she's eating an apple in
this sentence the object an apple is
emphasized because we already know she's
eating something but in Irish English
you can do this with a verb phrase too
is rain and it is without clefting this
would be it's raining it was always Dan
there she did without clefting it would
be she always danced there I'm sure you
can see that Irish English has numerous
features that set it apart from Standard
English and other spoken varieties of
English but I'm sure there will be Irish
people who watch this video and say we
don't say that that's because there are
various shades of Irish English if you
will there are Regional differences and
differences depending on the level of
formality and differences based on
socioeconomic status and the way people
want to express their identity in this
video I tried to focus on common
features that you'll likely hear in
Irish English even though you won't
always hear them if you're a speaker of
Irish English to what extent do you use
the features in this video or other
uniquely Irish features are there any
other Irish words or Expressions you'd
like to share with us write them in the
comments down below what are you
drinking prco Jesus it's far from prco
you were rared proo or proo is a type of
sparkling white wine named after a place
in Italy here you see another example of
clefting to show focus without clefting
this would be you were reared far from
proo this reply is an example of what
the Irish call beg gruder teasing
someone for behaving in a way that seems
above their perceived social class so
it's basically like saying what are you
drinking that fancy wine for you're not
that fancy beg gruder has historically
been an element of ir culture but from
what I hear it's becoming less and less
common which is probably a good thing a
special Thanks goes out to all of the
Lang Focus patreon supporters who make
videos like this possible especially the
ones whose names appear on the screen
they're the top tier patreon supporters
so let's give them a round of applause
if you liked this video you might also
like my video on the Irish language or
you might like to see more videos about
different varieties of English if so
check out my playlist on the English
language whichever you choose to watch
next I'm sure you'll find it f
fascinating